[Music]
and baby butthole news are you look at
me
sure about to have a baby oh you have a
baby uh not really not a baby no ma I
think him cheaper I doesn't mess with
his Buffalo more uh-huh yeah I can't
wait to mess with my stuff there's such
a pedophile tell you does it come off
the same when it's a mom submitted by
love from San Diego I'm Tiago Paula
Williams designer a vegan cafe responds
poorly to a bad review about a naked
baby in the restaurant a vegan cafe with
a naked baby in the restaurant are they
saying that people that are vegan or
more liberal and should be okay with a
naked baby yeah why I said it sounds it
does huh
because it feels like a barbecue like no
making babies in here
why does a diet preference have to be so
weird it's vertical I know it's just
like you just like eating vegetables
that fan it's a texture [ __ ] I think
it's attached to the lifestyle yeah I
don't know I'm not huge sound like
butthole so if I'm trying to eat
anything and buttholes around exactly
yeah it is a baby bottle it's cute the
whole I don't think so I mean it's
longer eating it's let's abuse that an
adult butthole but I still feel like a
hot key I think for me if I don't care
what restaurant I'm at if there's not a
naked but whole baby on my table I'm
cool
what if it's insight here is that
there's a good rule so like you're at
dinner there and we're at dinner here
this baby right there taking a [ __ ] and
the parents are eating the baby [ __ ] I
don't care okay I can't do that what is
the smell comes to your vicinity
he has hater blockers remember I just
like this push it back over there
I think this the idea butthole is it
great what I'm eating so this one in
that vegan cafe looks like a house is
that someone's house and then they just
converted the living room ah it looks
like it I'm not sure with the
restaurants called imagined vegan cafe
imagine imagine so this is in Memphis
Tennessee we've been there they have
great barbecue why are you going to a
vegan restaurant you're wrong if you go
they just need vegan options there yeah
this I find super hilarious so I'm going
to start off with this is the tweet that
went viral
it says meanwhile in Memphis a vegan
cafe is losing its mine on Facebook
because a Yelp reviewer said the owners
kids showed them their butthole do you
have an age on this kid yeah when you
know that yeah you look like a
three-month-old butthole like a
ten-year-old butthole they're a little
bit different it could be 15 to be a kid
true 15 year old butthole there is a
topic huh as to me 11 years old and down
the same bottle I don't care know if
back to our situation we have a dinner
we're having dinner and there's an 11
year old just laying down 11 Cheryl what
it's kind of what I don't want to see is
butthole and pubic hair 1111 so if it
bears issues if it's a pure angelic
Cupid like butthole no no 11 year old
bubbles that's why your paddle Barger
how many ships have you taking about 11
that thing is not it's not that pure no
more are you probably will have any
pimples on it what are you talking about
the first review says I've started at
all she's good hemorrhoid so they got a
kid Gibbs I just get hemorrhoids dude I
can't just hammer oh right now every
time I eat too much protein and not
enough fiber and everything else I just
get hemorrhoids then I don't understand
you ever wipe your ass with the tissue
and it looks like someone just used
Chinese calligraphy with the red ink on
it Oh having a [ __ ] period - the [ __ ]
I don't scrape that hard dirt has a
hemorrhage my six months I know I got a
hemorrhoid I'm not trying to [ __ ] cut
it open but it feels good on your white
part so my butthole itches and I can't
really scratch my butthole so I just
wipe it hard to feel scared that's what
you're supposed to just use the bidet if
you have just a Metamucil I think both
your shoes of the show really yeah
yeah yeah how many calories aren't
Metamucil though oh it's just five or so
whatever
okay but it's a good fiber washing it up
you have a bloody ass when you're gonna
ask me what role I'm going to be traded
with the bloody blood okay so I'm trying
to get rain I'm trying to get a lead
[ __ ] 200 [ __ ] pounds of whatever
hundred grams of fat in you're going to
be the buffest guy with a [ __ ]
hemorrhoid [ __ ] her intestines going
to be inside out yeah back to baby
buttholes yeah so there's a review
started at all it gave this restaurant
two stars it says on the real I eat here
all the time I still probably will
because I like to go out and there are a
few options available to me but y'all
listen during my visit a bare butt naked
baby was running around showed up on his
table with his black there so dirty
beats and bent over to show me its
butthole I like this kid oh my gosh
chimpanzee baby Joe I dance on tables
but not naked
yeah that here's me as black as black so
it continues I wish I was exaggerating
this is like while I'm eating and it's
the owners kids an older kid came over
and started like yodeling and staring at
me during my meal I was so uncomfortable
what the [ __ ] like I get it a family
establishment and kids through weird
things but make it baby running around
for like 15 minutes while all the
workers start started I think they meant
stared are just standing full subtle
English laughing isn't laughing over it
that's all I thought I can heat up it's
all freaky stuff sausage just as well
under half the time a toddler on a table
though I'm more afraid of the taller
being hurt than the [ __ ] being shown
what the hell is a toddler - how old is
this kid under 5 is toddler like a
bubble wonders as this kid is 21 months
old why do moms talk about
I don't [ __ ] know I also what other
kinds of like wonderful I'm gonna keep
oh yeah you know you have the baby in
one thing I'm 256 they're alike by 142
year old months you know 142 yeah who
doesn't but it's a true baby I was under
two years old right yeah I so I don't
want to sound like bar but yeah that's a
that's a better situation of the perfect
a year and a half yes yeah
I'm welcome to us whatever no it is the
yodeling sounds a little weird I
probably more annoyed by that like bro
your Tina to chop yeah so then imagine
being a cafe on their facebook page
which is not deleted by the way they
posted all of us to start calling out
names and pictures of people who leave
us bad reviews especially when it deals
with our children you will no longer be
allowed to come and dine at imagine
Desperados I know right especially when
you lie about our babies we do not need
or want your business be our guests to
go and eat at other vegan restaurants
down the street this is going to be fun
for exclamation marks you've thoroughly
irritated mama bear and a [ __ ] ton of
exclamation mark we're starting with
Chelsea Bartley which is the review I
just read for anyone who reads this and
instantly is scared this might affect
our business I cannot begin to tell you
how much we don't care haters are not
welcome at they don't care because they
took the time the [ __ ] respond yeah
when you yeah yeah is she saying that
this wasn't true like it sounds like
she's saying it is true okay it sounds
like she's kind of like saying like this
is what we do like [ __ ] you like my
babies buttholes gonna be out here
hahahaha we are here that's exactly our
yeah I mean because I'm there responding
to comments on that Facebook post you
can't take a little butthole you can't
hear ya I come on stand your ground
don't be a little [ __ ] I kind of like
that so then they respond to someone
saying something like if it was me and a
one-year-old was upside down on a table
showing everyone the butthole I don't
think it's the biggest problem I would
be wondering well no one's grabbing that
baby off the table if she wearing factor
that on top of the table you grown
adults to sit around and wait for her to
fall if that were me I would instantly
grab an adult or grab the baby before
they fell that's what the mom or the
owner what if I was a naked baby with
the helmet and it's okay no sir
responded with I'm certainly not going
to touch someone's naked baby too much
of a liability jeez you just recommend
random naked baby off the table
dumbfounded I would roundhouse the baby
off the table I'm looking you're trading
dark now baby off to keep responding
Lauren bang Facebook's a weird spot man
Facebook is a weird place they're going
in right now just like these are my
children she's talking about she's
complaining about our five-year-old
coming over and talking to her in our 21
month old I understand your point but if
you aren't uncomfortable with the naked
baby then do not come to our restaurant
periodically she will not have a diaper
on and that is life I actually like
family restaurants where the kids are
[ __ ] running around because I feel
like it's it's like their pets just
coming over to say hi didn't that lady
in the review say she likes to go there
yes she's in everything so so I'm a joke
I'm officer to view I don't like that
but then once I've been there I just
don't go back I don't complain about it
and if you like that you go back yeah
rather than like keep going and like oh
this time the kid is diaper no shirt you
know next time you can see it but
exactly you know what to expect
that's the branding of the place man
yeah yeah which is fine yeah it's not
for everybody but it's fine
get your salad in a naked baby too
that's what that's the place all parts
there you know what it's like their
environment is like come to our house
where it's the living room of the family
feel like you're right at your own area
and with even a look at the place
someone said like all of its like a
house it does look like a so I think you
know what you're getting into because if
I went to my family's and there's a
[ __ ] make a baby running around
whatever it happens so that original
tweet of the person who found this whole
drama online that tweet I was reading
the thread and it was so [ __ ] funny
because someone went on their page on
the café's page and they dug up an older
post saying something like will be
closed today due to us accidentally
running over an 85 year old woman with
our super dark car and then she's like
they're like as she was rushed to the
hospital she's alive
but it was the incident was horrible
this is the
the restaurant director saying like why
we're there updating people on Facebook
I want to follow any more once you say
that close for the day are they doing
this as a joke who are these young
readers oh well they're very personal
yeah that's very honest I'm going to
read through the post we will be closed
today Jun tend to recover mentally and
emotionally from a devastating accident
we were involved in last night we were
traveling home from imagine last night
when an 85 year old woman with dementia
walked right out in front of our cart at
Lamar and Bellevue we instantly slammed
on the brakes but it was too late our
vehicle shook her and she was rushed to
the Med she is still currently alive but
the incident was horrific not only alive
that music is not lasting long not only
for Adam who was driving but for all our
babies our man is not drivable but we
are grateful to the University I was a
big old a please be patient with us as
we deal with the tragedy and thank you
for understanding and in that Twitter
thread where they put is this screenshot
someone replied with for some reason I'm
just not at all surprised that a vegan
with wild free-range children can't
drive her micro bus very well and then
people are responding with to help you
agent I feel like a bee cage free cage
free children leaving the hell of a
thing on the internet like a good thing
it isn't yes what I mean it's like a
cult huh I don't know I'm just worried
when someone says they're vegan I just
go
I mean Kim's friend his girlfriend she's
really gonna know and she's the one
vegan that is just shattering the
stereotypes for me because she's totally
not like vegan yeah like all those jokes
like how do you know someone's vegan or
something they probably told you hey
what did the first five seconds or
whatever and it's kind of true hope you
guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hey
ah
[Music]